hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play knock knock no
we're back in the real house with no
monsters in it thankfully unless the
monsters are suddenly gonna start
pouring into this world which I don't
know maybe they are gonna maybe not who
knows whatever don't we care long hair
don't care well I just got to do is I
got to figure out what I am doing we
planted the forest to hide one tree what
I don't get it
why did I write this in my sleep what
does it even mean No thank you no one's
home go away this looks like a dismal
place but I feel at peace here ordinary
forest topsoil clay sand leaves in
compost a normal force the way it should
be if you say so man I'm not gonna
question you question you alright anyway
so this guy he thinks he's sleeping in
both times he goes to sleep in one wakes
up in the other world no wonder he looks
so had heard Haggard you're a wizard
Harry ruby is tacky
I'm looking for pages what I'm doing no
thank you don't want any not buying any
Girl Scout cookies today
I've got many other problems to deal
with okay have him find anything else
man see a few more rooms for the end I
still think someone's gonna pop out at
any minute him shut up shut up don't
wanna hear any of it it takes simple
samples of the air every day humidity is
the same composition do nitrogen and
oxygen the land hasn't changed much in
eons everything's the same as it was
from my ancestors it's just that the
lands written as richness is in decline
taking note of it day after day is my
job if you say so how do you get paid
for this job if you're alone in the
woods
okay I won't question it anymore all
right everything's quiet no wolves or
owls only frogs and gnats if you say so
man done questioning you let's just go
it's like time doesn't pass unless I do
that thing I don't know why and the door
is open I'm gonna find this girl I have
a feeling like I accidentally missed out
on the last one I haven't read the
comments yet cuz I haven't posted this
video but very intrigued as to the
mystery of what is going on who is this
girl and what does she represent is she
the voice that I hear in my waking
nightmares maybe you know maybe I don't
you know oh hey I just take one big lap
around the house and that's it okay
everyone look out very carefully for her
keep an eye out let me know if you see
something not gonna miss her this time
I'm not gonna be distracted by any
stories Moosman or otherwise merely
looking for where this girl is what was
that what is that said there wouldn't be
any wolves der damn it I didn't see her
gotta be here gotta be here somewhere
darkness someone said that it was very
important that I find her so I could get
the good ending I didn't know there were
multiple endings what that kind of had a
direction to it that a hint hello hello
anybody come on I thought you said there
weren't any owls it was aha
I see her wow she was up against the
tree aah aah aah come on
ok I guess that was it I did find her I
did was my house now give me my house
fine I found her I did what was that was
that a ghost Teague oh no where's my
house my house go she was really hard to
spot because she was in the silhouette
of a tree where's my house my house
where's my house damn it did I just get
lost in the woods is that even possible
I don't know oh come on where's my house
I need to get back inside got a game to
play
everybody's waiting on me hello my house
where the hell is my house where is it I
wasn't this far what is going on here
I'm so confused
wha it's gone my house is just plain and
simple gone maybe I went maybe I thought
it like loop front to back but maybe it
didn't hang on me
aha oh it doesn't loop front to back I
thought it did ok
the woods are much harder to navigate
that I previously thought but anyway
back into the dream world once again
trying to solve the mystery before I get
to whatever these other symbols mean
wake up again in this house that you
don't know
okay all right let's get started shall
we
I think this house has a big house
Jesus why does your house keep changing
man okay come on
cook up something good nope that's not
that good it's hiding place I guess
that's all I can really ask for Oh
oh I do not like trouncing through these
dark houses has to admit the obvious but
he doesn't know how
it's beyond him what there are fewer and
fewer blank pages left okay imagine
something good like this okay
nothing in okay now is helpful no no
nothing none up there yeah I don't think
anything's in the house just yet I think
I'm still good at least for the time
being
oh come on I interrupted him come on
imagine something good what I don't do
that I'm not doing that I am not turning
out the light any minute now buddy what
that's hardly useful come on
something better I guess I can't you ask
too much of him he's already insane
what's a little more okay
what this is a crawl crawling out from
the inside not crawling in from the
outside at all the horror from the woods
is in my house what does that mean what
horror in the woods I just had to say
them what horror in the woods stop
getting distracted and imagine whatever
crap you're gonna put in this place any
minute now
you all right be good oh oh I was a bit
too soon Lee already which door did he
block out though oh wait what you gonna
make you're gonna make something else oh
that is not so good what's that
squishing something is a squishing what
is this pushing
what's the squish question uh-huh what
is that what that's question what is
creepy what goes squish squish in the
night I don't want to know
whoa what do you mean this is a wrong
house
what was it wait I just saw handprints
on the walls what are going squished
guess I better find out hey I'm almost
I'm almost to dawn I'm doing good I
found to time things let's not play how
about that
Lee appears wispy why what what maybe
mean what what is that
let's check her out
Oh forest debris earth and bone ah I
didn't even see it was on the ground
what was it I don't even know oh not
fair those things could go through walls
sometime no not a peep I mister I how
you doing huh are you good oh that's
shook up my sanity
another time ding I'm getting lots of
these things today tonight lately oh
that wasn't a very good one I don't hear
anything going home
oh well that doesn't bother me he's up
there and I'm down here so hopefully
that won't be a problem
come on hurry up man there's no time for
this what the hell is that
hi okay never mind he can come down he
can he can do that thing I think that's
the way I need to go to get to the rest
of the house so I'm not sure what else I
need to do oh I don't even know what
this is doing by me imagining these
random objects in these rooms okay
oh it's behind that door Hey look bad
babel twin expedition is it hey what
what what listen what happened am I able
what what's going on wait what whoa whoa
whoa buddy what is going on here where
you go
what is going on
Oh real good news oh hi oh you're home
what does that mean
whoa what there's another what oh no I
don't seem to be doing anything what's
going on
ah that was a big knock knock on the
door who's the kid okay I don't think
I'm supposed to open it but I'm an open
then anyway you know what cuz I live on
the edge nope I'm opening it I feel like
there's something wicked on the other
side of the door it's calling to me
that's why I want to open it but oh god
it won't let me open to it alright fine
I won't open in jeez what is going on
things have changed you're right where
well what would that whoa what what what
happened I don't know what happened what
happened what happened it's like that
guy merged into me what
I'm so confused I'm so confused
I don't know what just happened
come on give me a time thing or
something
come on no I don't know what the hell
that is whatever okay I'm so confused I
don't know what is going on there
there's something blocking up that door
now I can't get through that big door
I can't even okay I can scroll out I
can't get through that door what do I do
what like do what do I do
I don't know
and now I can get through what is going
on footprints say well that's not time
wait no I need to see where these
footprints go there's footprints in
there and they're leading into this room
does it mean I'm gonna run out anyway oh
you're just giving me time things now
you want this to end don't you fine I
need to see I need to know I need to
know what's real I need to know it's
done it's over now
what happened
oh no idea welcome the guests set the
table put plates and cups on it in the
center a simple round loaf of bread you
can cover the cups with pieces of paper
a dead maple leaves don't turn off the
light but deuce - close your eyes
imagine the faces of people that appear
at the table one after the other these
are your guests oh well that's more sad
than anything alright well that's it
then
what is going on I'm so curious
ah so cares I'm so curious as to what is
going on I'm so good views it's too cool
it's so cool alright way I'm done
geeking out about it anyway it's all the
time I got for this one too so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
by some reason the scattered
what did I just do
close it
Oh
god
my doing with my life oh that's me when
I